not giving a [ __ ] about anybody else's
opinion is the secret sauce right like
if you really ask me to deconstruct why
I think I'm gonna win I'm empathetic
about other people's opinions I respect
other people's opinions and I really do
I'm a listener for all my talking at the
end of the day I just don't think it's
practical to live my life by somebody
else's North Star
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up vlog super excited now for
this talk here in Gothenburg Sweden one
of the great things about traveling the
world is maybe going to that city or two
or three that isn't Stockholm or the pry
or in Germany Berlin going to you know
second third fourth cities kind of no
different than when people come to the
US and do go to a Chicago or or San
Francisco or a Boston or a Miami and so
I love that part
great audience Gore just set up in there
hopefully Babbitt will get some context
and we'll go give it our best at-bat
Gary crush the keynote as usual but this
question from the Q&A I could answer
this you not to go any further this is
very classic you know and being an
immigrant I understand it deeply so many
of us love our parents very much very
common and tight-knit families
immigrants Southeast Asia Italy you know
Eastern Europe a lot of a lot of cliche
talk India let me talk let me tell every
young person in here and everybody who's
watching why I tell them the very harsh
advice of going against their parents in
their 20s if you appease your parents in
your 20s to live the life they want you
to you will not have a relationship with
your parents in your 40s 50s 60s and 70s
it's just a long game there's nothing
worse than resenting your parents and so
the upfront friction of fighting in your
20s and not becoming a doctor or lawyer
let's get this man a mic the upfront
friction of not becoming a doctor or
lawyer or professor in your 20s to make
your parents happy because they grew up
in a different game at a different time
I think is far more a better play
because regret and resent fulness is
super scary and very ugly and I think
it's the
worst of the two evils yeah compared to
yeah I I really don't want it to be like
this effect but I know a lot of people
are going through the same situation 23
years old like the first two years of
our for my mother was like right then my
dream as a father yes full-time at a
daycare center yep and then evenings
weekends and then I was like after that
I was full time two years out and so I
just sing us a song speaking about yep
do you say so for Southeast Asian yeah
yep it's all about like the case of my
brother I understand I was born in the
Soviet Russia your kids are the
byproduct of you and how you look to
other other parents you're a product and
dead on dude let me ask you a question
whose fault do you think it is that you
and your mother don't have a
relationship
me too I agree I guess I get it yes of
course
all right let's play out the guys life
is about choices
there's no this is this is binary you
either did that and took the risk and
the hope that if you were successful
because you believed in yourself to be
able to make that leap
you believed right and you had no choice
you believed and hoped that you'd be
able to backtrack into a relationship
after you
right I mean that's the practical thing
the alternative would be that you'd be
sitting you would be fundamentally more
unhappy right now and that's with not
having a relationship with your mother
theoretically it sucks on paper
everybody who loves their mother I mean
I my mother is my idol everybody who
loves their mother right now and here's
you know have a relationship goes that
sucks
unless they've lived a life where they
lived by their parents terms and
realized the cancer that was running
through their head in their heart every
day of their lives forever my man I
would just go on the offense to try to
have a relationship with your mother
suffocate her I don't mean physically
like like it takes two to tango to have
a relationship you could smother her you
could email her you could send her
videos you could send her gifts you
could show up at her job you could of
course correct when's the last time you
talked to her and what was the
conversation
no [ __ ] and do you have siblings
understand understood I would suffocate
her I'm being serious do you desperately
want the relationship so then act like
it
stop [ __ ] pondering in your head and
just go [ __ ] attack I know I know
you're doing the right thing because
we're one minute and 15 seconds over
however I'm thanked I'm asking for two
or three more minutes on this because
this is a pretty important [ __ ] is that
cool can I get two minutes brother
brother suffocate her in the same way
don't listen
don't be the reverse of who you are at
18 at 18 you made a binary decision
high-risk high-reward that you're gonna
go do this either you have to ask
yourself if you want the relationship
because you've already shown me that you
have the ability to make the tough
decision you did it you have to ask
yourself and you don't you shouldn't
give a [ __ ] about this audience or me or
anybody else or Hasan Minhaj you need to
be in your own head I think it's
appropriate to not who you want that
negativity in your life it's your mouth
course dude of course brother and it
should and by the way that's awesome and
it should but if you want it if you've
decided through that one relationship
that you want the relationship
act like it suffocate her just like pop
like when she's walking down the street
come out of the alley and be like blue
half like it thank you
[Applause]
yes sir you're welcome sir take care we
gotta go
you missed a good part there's audio to
it it happened the cameras down the guy
asked me about Tesla and I was talking
about
I mean long-term or short-term
I don't know that business well enough
now I believe in Elon the most yeah but
I I understand media and retail and what
Facebook and Amazon do I just don't
understand transportation now
theoretically in my binary bet on the
bet on the jockey not the horse yeah
Elon every day he's doing it I think I
think sighs I think so too
where is what I was saying up there I
know you understand it's a difference
that's such an interesting blood and
it's such an interesting distinction
like I talked about what I know the
cryptocurrency trying to think of other
themes even machine learning VR they are
my thoughts I'm in the I think you guys
are in full time I think the people that
win are in the I know I know this stuff
content underpriced attention this
moment I know that's a big [ __ ]
fundamental difference between thinking
and knowing and acting on your knowing
full and being thoughtful about your
thinking and being cautious to learn
until no that is a big difference
between winning and losing so many
people so many of you were all in I want
you think that's something you have to
think about about to do
Jim Rome's podcast Jim Rome a legend in
the sports announcing sports
commentating industry I'm really excited
about it actually I've done his radio
show went pretty viral we've had dinner
I'm just a fan of his vibe
so I'm excited about this this is what
happens should be some highlights here
like worked in a store retail every
Saturday is the biggest day of the week
like gave up my my social life my 20s
dude alpha DNA left it on the table went
into my early 30s now married and still
making 40 70 80 90 thousand dollars a
year [ __ ] solid but building something
of that wealth and then leaving at 34
with no money on paper I can't go buy a
better home because I have no equity in
anything by all standards not worth
anything and then during that whole time
of building this big business for my dad
having all my friends and acquaintances
and my friend's parents say things like
oh what scary you know asking my good
friends from high school when they were
26 what's Gary Vaynerchuk up to oh he
works at his dad's liquor store like
like you know you know right now in a
world where a list celebrities are
reaching out to me super smart and cool
and historically successful people like
you are fascinated by me like it's all
easy now I'm in the [ __ ] eating business
Jim I'm in the [ __ ] eating business
right now Jim you know any people right
now listening to this or like like right
this second your audience which you know
I'm one of but because of the certain
thing I just said or who the hell knows
because of the mentality of them looking
for excuses ah as you know it's a
constant game of eating [ __ ] with more
attention you know I'm you know I'm
getting called out on ludicrous [ __ ]
like you know how it is I mean it just
it's just part of the process anybody
who's listening right now if you have
real ambitions if you really want to win
the great thing to learn is how to eat
[ __ ] aka get used to people criticizing
understand that people default into
cynicism 90% of people aren't unhappy
and they want to drag you down and you
shouldn't be mad at them they're not
trolls
you know everybody who shits on me I
have empathy for because if they have
energy to [ __ ] on me they're in such a
bad place
themselves that they want somebody else
to be there with them so I'm not mad at
people at Twitter saying I suck or I'm
full of [ __ ] or daddy put me on I feel
bad for them I'm excited now just gave a
great podcast - Jim - Jim Rome I
definitely am gonna blast that out to
all of you babban loved it we also just
made a little reference to what my
financial situation was when I left Wine
Library I think for a lot of you it's
something that is left out of the story
and will be clarifying that but with all
that fun that's all very secondary to my
favorite moment of every episode oh [ __ ]
I've [ __ ] left my hoodie I'm sad now
I like that hoodie the hoodie that I was
a twin with you anyway no dwelling about
the hoodie they excuse me the beanie
because what's amazing about Airport
Gary is when you're the greatest
superhero on earth you've always got a
backup beanie yeah you know Batman's got
multiple things in that belt Airport
Gary the greatest superhero on earth he
is not set back by the beanie being left
in the hotel room because he slept with
it coz it was cold in the bed he has a
backup and he is now almost officially
ready to dominate domination time
[Music]